non viviamo in un mondo per
non viviamo nemmeno nel mondo che ci
piacerebbe immaginare
viviamo in un mondo nel quale
l'imprenditoria femminile in generale ed
in agricoltura in particolare continua
ad essere più un caso isolato che è un
esempio di successo alla portata di
tutti ma io non voglio stare qui a
parlarvi della difficoltà di essere una
donna una madre una moglie è un
imprenditore di cosa vuol dire
fronteggiare ogni giorno le aspettative
della società sul ruolo di una donna ma
anche se più semplicemente le difficoltà
di relazionarmi ogni giorno con la
piccola comunità agricola che opera
nella mia azienda è che ha dei
pregiudizi nei miei confronti
io invece vi voglio parlare di quella
che è la mia esperienza imprenditoriale
è di successo nell'appunto
nell'agricoltura e di come il mio
approccio da imprenditore agricolo vero
e proprio stia nel suo piccolo innovando
la mia azienda e per farlo
ritengo importante iniziare da quella
che è la mia formazione perché io sono
laureato in agraria triennale
specialistica o conseguito un dottorato
di ricerca in frutticoltura mediterranea
e durante questo iter formativo non ho
fatto altro che studiare vedere imparare
tutto quello che adesso sto cercando di
applicare nella mia azienda
adesso io gestisco l'azienda di famiglia
quella che un tempo era gestita così da
mio padre ed a mio nonno e adesso la
gestisco io
una donna anche relativamente giovane
so che avrei detto che non avevo detto
che non avrei parlato più ma
indiscutibilmente purtroppo la prima
anomalia diciamo che è stata riscontrata
nella gestione dell'azienda o anche
ampliato e variato l'indirizzo culturale
dell'azienda che prima coltivava
soltanto agrumi e adesso coltiva anche
piante tropicali
si tratta di piante che il mio nonno
probabilmente nemmeno conosceva perché
ai suoi tempi erano coltivate
letteralmente soltanto dall'altra parte
del mondo e cerco di gestire l'azienda
considerandola come un business
considerando l'agricoltura come
un'attività produttiva a tutti gli
effetti e non soltanto come una mera
attività di sussistenza tradizionale che
è come più o meno siamo abituati a
interpretare l'agricoltura qui in
sicilia la mia azienda agricola l'ho
fondata nel nel 2015 lo ampliata l'ho
fatta diventare quello che è oggi
utilizzando dei fondi europei e quindi
imparando a utilizzare anche tutti gli
strumenti della programmazione nazionale
per regionale tramite i piani di
sviluppo rurale che lo stato italiano
mette alle regioni mettono a
disposizione degli imprenditori agricoli
anche questa purtroppo è una piccola
anomalia considerato che ancora troppo
pochi sono gli agricoltori che non
reputano che il ruolo di imprenditore
debba appartenergli e che quindi non
reputano nemmeno necessario imparare a
utilizzare questi strumenti per davvero
io l'ho fatto
e così ho ricavato la mia azienda una
piccola area una piccola oasi tuttavia
nella quale io posso sperimentare ed
innovare come meglio credo all'interno
del più grande corpo stazion dal e sono
un totale di sette ettari suddivisi tra
[Musica]
coltivazioni di agrumi soprattutto il
limone che la cultura più tradizionale
della zona e colture tropicali mango
sotto serra è avvocato in pieno campo
la scelta di coniugare tradizione e
innovazione non è stata casuale perché
uno dei miei punti di base
io ritengo che l'agricoltura sia
un'attività che ha costantemente bisogno
di essere rinnovata ma ha bisogno di
essere ignorata per potersi migliorare
non necessariamente per dovere
radicalmente cambiare cambiare se stessa
e cambiare faccia io sono una grande fan
dell innovazione incrementale come dice
schumpeter e non dell'incredibile
innovazione radicale
io penso che questo sia l'unico connubio
che possa garantire la sostenibilità
dell'agricoltura
per quanto riguarda la parte più
innovativa della mia azienda è come
forse avete visto inizialmente
caratterizzata da una serra molto grande
e molto bella che ha una struttura molto
moderna di circa 3.200 metri quadri che
è dotata di sensori automatizzate che
regolano la temperatura e l'umidità è è
il vento all'interno della serra in modo
che le colture possano sempre avere le
condizioni ottimali per il loro sviluppo
ma la serra e anche
uno di quei metodi produttivi che con la
sostenibilità solitamente non va molto
d'accordo perché richiede alti input
immissioni di alti input al suo interno
nello specifico le piante vengono sempre
tenute al loro massimo livello
produttivo e di crescita
cosa che necessita un sostegno esterno
sia in qualità di apporto idrico che
nutrizionale entrambi questi fabbisogni
vengono soddisfatti e utilizzando la
fertirrigazione che è una tecnica
irrigua che prevede di di sciogliere in
acqua gli elementi nutritivi che così
vengono direttamente assorbiti dalle
radici e dall'apparato radicale
questo metodo è sì molto efficiente ma
rischia anche di essere ambientalmente
poco sostenibile perché potendo portare
nel lungo periodo ad accumulo di questi
elementi nelle acque di falda per
ovviare a questo inconveniente è anche a
quello delle necessità idriche
ho creato un sistema di raccolta e il
riciclo delle acque meteoriche e delle
acque della fertirrigazione riuscendo
così a mantenere il più possibile
appunto la sostenibilità della serra e
dell'azienda siano un punto di vista
ambientale ma anche da un punto di vista
economico perché la sostenibilità e sia
ambientale ma è anche degli operatori
dell'agricoltore perché perché
l'agricoltura è sempre comunque
un'attività produttiva anche per quanto
riguarda gli appezzamenti in pieno canto
di avvocato e di limone sono molto
moderni hanno sistemi di irrigazione
di microirrigazione localizzata in modo
da ridurre gli sprechi idrici e
massimizzare l'efficienza di utilizzo
dell'acqua hanno anche dei sistemi di
drenaggio per salvaguardare l'apparato
radicale delle piante garantirne una
produzione elevata è di ottima qualità
nel tempo ma non è questo a mio avviso
non è questo il vero lato innovativo di
quello che ho fatto di quello che faccio
non è la non è stata la grande idea che
è stata sicuramente un'ottima idea di
piantare le tropicali in sicilia perché
è una scelta che hanno fatto anche altri
quello che non hanno fatto anche altri è
il passaggio lo switch da agricoltore a
imprenditore che è quello che invece io
cerco di fare ogni giorno io cerco di
guidare la mia azienda e di rispondere
alle necessità e alle domande che mi si
presentano ogni giorno con un approccio
imprenditoriale applicando il cosiddetto
lateral thinking
io cerco di non arrivare impreparata
alle scelte cerco di non arrivare
impreparata alle criticità in conto
sulla mia formazione è conto sul mio
approccio ma soprattutto conto sul fatto
che non mi fermerò mai non crederò mai a
quei limiti che se solo io ci credessi
anche solo per un attimo la società
nella quale io però mi imporrebbe
[Applauso]